stuff we're gonna make the mix what do
you think of growing up the smell and
the tastes of amazing crumpet and never
leaves you to make the mix the secret is
to bring your milk up the ball but do
not boil it the minute it boils turn it
off and let it sit there now
flour in a nice pinch of salt in now add
half a teaspoon of bicarb that gives it
aeration and really lifts the mixture up
all those lovely little holes a nice
pinch of sugar and then a teaspoon of
yeast dry yeast
now once the mills balled turn it off
and add some warm water about 10
tablespoons 150 mil that cools down the
milk but more importantly it doesn't
destroy the yeast half of the milk in
first stop and give that a really good
mix now the rest of it
[Music]
you can just see that there's no lumps
through there as it drips through the
whisk now we're looking for it to double
in size and get nice and light so pop in
the warm place whilst you get on with
the delicious topping beautiful
strawberries but caramelize almost like
a very quick strawberry jam and on just
slice these in half
some sugar a couple of tablespoons we're
gonna take the sugar to a nice light
camera it's just starting to change
color now turn the gas down whether I
have the strawberries beautiful it's
sweating the strawberries down quickly
and the caramels breaking down a
wonderful glaze on the strawberries some
lemon grated into the strawberries gives
it that kind of freshness that really
starts to break down the strawberries
nice gas up smells incredible some lemon
juice
touch of balsamic vinegar and that gives
it a really nice delicious tartness now
off the goes as the strawberries start
to cool down naturally thicken them set
beautifully nice
now for the crumpet it's almost doubled
in size but be very careful you don't
knock the ball because it can sort of
push out all that air it's variated is
nicest light just see the texture she's
ready to go did you boil it
[Music]
in Riga instead of making normal small
crumpets I'm making a giant one ideal
for sharing now turn the gas down you
just start to see a traditional crumpet
style cooking process we want those nice
tiny little holes on top and then crispy
crunchy base right now it's time to add
the butter just slide the butter down
the bag that gives it a really nice
nutty flavor at the end fish nice flip
beautiful take that out
take the champ dispute over the secret
is for the juicer sort of run inside all
those that will hold think of that
tartness of the balsamic vinegar the
strawberries beautifully soft and always
pureed wrapped and at the delicious can
now finish that with a nice ball of
creme fraiche let that sit there and
that is an amazing way of finishing off
a traditional brunch with something
sweet something delicious and something
your died to tuck into
[Music]
it's almost like slicing through butter
in the knife do the work
this is eggs to the nth degree
packed with different tastes textures
and flavors all working wonderfully
together perfect
[Music]